what up space fam Goldson here from
anime Opera back at it again to discuss
the latest and craziest developments in
the one piece story in this one we see a
lot of stuff that we were waiting for
including Kuma's backstory the fate of
Vivi which is huge Luffy Waging War on
the world government and much more so
make sure to stay tuned for that if you
do enjoy these weekly one piece reviews
I want to keep them coming cello parking
with them and smash that like button
it's always better to be a smashing
Power King than a passing Orochi and
join the nakama if you haven't by
subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications over 50 of you are
subscribed and you might not even know
it so just take a second to check and
that way you ensure you'll get notified
about the latest one piece chapters and
updates and now without further Ado
let's jump into It spoilers and all this
chapter is called Mark 3 and the
implications of that title are big as
we'll see soon some World Government men
are not happy about a government weapon
getting in their way on Egghead this
appears to be the latest version of the
government pacifistas that take the form
of Kuma if you pay attention to the
pacifista's clothing there is a Roman
numeral 3 on it so you may have already
guessed that Mark 3 in the title is
referring to these new and improved
pacifistas the pacifista has a bubble
Shield that's easy to manipulate but
strong and can easily block even
hardcore Firepower it also reflects the
explosion back at the opponent which is
amazing the bubble Shield is described
as the Ultimate Defense and isn't that
just classic Oda for the Ultimate
Defense to be a bubble Shield then they
mention outright that this must be a
Mark III pacifista far more advanced
than the prototypes used in the summit
war and in the summit War the past
episodes were overshadowed by most of
the legendary figures there but these
new ones plus the seraphims would
definitely have made much more of a
splash back then not to mention this
pacifista is huge towering over the
others like a giant it speaks telling
them to proceed to factory B and the
guys agree saying if they don't do what
it says they'll die keep in mind this is
one pacifista totally outclassing them
like this that would be important to
remember for later on as they're
wondering who gave the order to the
pacifista we jump to centumaru who is
not dead yet he comments that the
frontier Dome is sealed and that he
can't get a hold of grandpa Punk he
remembers Luffy promising to get back a
buck off the island we find out that the
Navy is trying to reach santomaru still
not realizing that he's become a rebel
like vegapunk since he's already a rebel
he decides he can do whatever he wants
in all 50 yes 50 50 Mark III units are
prepared for deployment now this would
be epic if we didn't find out last
chapter that one of the elders one of
the five Elders specifically is coming
and will in all likelihood make the
pacifists change sides using his greater
Authority I'm sure like me none of these
characters expected an elder to show up
so otherwise this would have looked very
good for our side for now though sento
Maru gives the order to them to help a
Vega Punk Get on Luffy's ship and for
them to set sails safely he assumes the
Navy has something up their sleeves and
tells them to stand guard at the coast
the Egghead inhabitants are wowed by the
pacifistas and comment on how something
is going to go down on this island soon
I mean it already has been going down
but I'm sure that'll look like Child's
Play compared to what's gonna go down
soon in a big way santomaru's final
words are no matter what happens the
pacifist does must ensure their creator
escapes definitely glad santomaru is on
our side and I always respect seeing
such resolve to do the right thing even
at such great personal costs we then
jump to where the others are Luffy could
not find vegapunk as he explains he's
visibly sweating and panting saying he
ran all over the place looking he even
broke his hover boots from running so
much Luffy hilariously says don't snitch
I can't pay them back such a Luffy thing
to say as if the fact that he's saving
vegapunk's life doesn't more than make
up for some broken boots that punk does
locate Bonnie from the looks of it he
says everything in the lap is
transmitted on the monitors and Luffy is
obviously upset saying he could have
told him sooner that was a lot of
running around that he did for nothing
we also get outfit changes for Brook and
Stussy Zorro looks especially cool and
stussy's outfit again makes us see why
Whitebeard might have very well fathered
Weevil with a younger Stussy like this
one as usual though there are
complications things seem calm right now
but it's definitely the Calm before the
storm the Stella AKA main vegapunk body
disappeared and they've lost control of
the frontier dome which is random and I
hope that has a good explanation they're
basically trapped in the lab bull
stratum we're told which is horrible
because it gives the Marines time for
their reinforcements to get here
including at least one Admiral and at
least one Elder again I'm wondering how
strong the elders actually are Daft Punk
tells us if anyone tried to leave the
lasers would fry them so Oda is pretty
much setting it up here that they have
to wait for this conflict to happen
because they literally can't get out
before that which I'm kind of fine with
because I do think this will be an epic
conflict and it would be anticlimactic
if they just missed Admiral kizaru and
the Elder Daft Punk wants the others to
find Stella while he figures out a way
to repair the Dome the dull
malfunctioning again seems super
inconvenient and super bad timing so
there better be a satisfying explanation
for it then that buck explains that he
can't find style through the monitors
because of the seraphim rampage that
happened it incapacitated some of the
baby monitor snails or they were knocked
out of position by the way before moving
on I just want to say that there was a
manga panel of everyone together and it
showed Nami seemingly stomping on a
captured and passed out Lucci while
Robin tried to calm her down pretty
funny detail right there and of course
the whole time Sanji is gushing hearts
and eyes and everything over one female
he sees or another but back to the
snails and Daft Punk assumes that Stella
is in a blind spot some other satellites
are searching trying to find him when
some characters decide to help and look
Sanji is quick to beg slussy to take him
with her Sanji pulling a white beard
over here we get a hilarious moment when
Zorro mentions he'll try to help too
Sanji points out that if he goes to find
someone who's going to find him when
he's done it's hilarious but accurate
and Oda did a great job with
illustrating sanji's facial expression
here they all see the point and ask Zoro
to stay I absolutely love that moment
the funniest of the chapter so you have
Luffy and Zoro chilling on the couch
while we see a knockdown Luchi and Kaku
in front of them the concept focus on
them definitely makes it seem like they
may come into play again soon Luffy is
still tired from running all out so
hopefully that won't come back to hurt
him if he needs to fight again soon we
then jump to Bonnie who as we guessed
has entered a sort of memory world we
see a kid Kuma beat up and crying some
people catch up to him as the kid begs
to be saved and begs not to be taken
back however the people taking him back
say he has to because they'll get killed
if he escapes in this memory world no
matter how much Bonnie tries to get
closer to her father she can't she can
just watch from a distance kid Kuma begs
to be killed instead of going back he
says if he goes back he'll die anyway
it's hard to watch he's crying and
Bonnie is crying as well the shadowy
figures raise what looks like bats or it
may even be just sticks and hit Kuma as
Bonnie cries for them to stop it's so
hard to watch for Bonnie that she is
thrown back from the memory bubble she's
shaking and we briefly see current day
Kuma climbing again as I said why he's
climbing will definitely be revealed in
these memories and I think soon Bonnie
comments that she couldn't take it all
in but she's determined thinking if she
stays ignorant she'll never be able to
understand then a satellite sees an
explosion but of course it's left as a
cliffhanger either way seems things are
going down in a big way next chapter in
this chapter is far from over yet in
fact some of the biggest news is yet to
come we jump to big news Morgan so yeah
pun kind of intended he got the news
that the world government intends to
assassinate the Beloved vegapunk the
world's greatest genius he says it's
like Ohara again but even worse because
the doctor is far too popular for that
to fly he's loved as the man that
develops energy to light up towns the
world over another detail that sounds
very much like what scientist Nikola
Tesla strive to do I really like the
idea of the heroic scientist here
Morgan's also knows Luffy as at the
scene so he gets the idea for a headline
Navy Skirmish at Egghead Emperor Straw
Hat Luffy takes vegapunk hostage
although it's clearly Incorrect and he
even knows it's incorrect I am excited
for Luffy's notoriety to build in the
world Emperor's bounty to reach insane
numbers and this should definitely help
with that Morgans does this because he
knows the government will appreciate
that more than the truth and according
to him he wants to collect a
contribution from them as Vega Punk made
clear earlier the government is where
the money is and to use their money you
gotta keep them happy we then get the
big reveal that Vivi and by the way
waffle 2 are with Morgans she says Luffy
would never do that wah pool is just
freaked out though worried that if the
government had a wiretap snail here they
might find out where the two are and
erase them it's explained that Morgans
took them in he's definitely an
interesting character one that can't
just be written off as simply good or
bad but operates in the gray area very
well he calls Vivi out for bawling her
eyes out yesterday and tells her not to
interfere with his job he says his words
can shake the world and besides news
isn't about facts or fiction but about
entertainment and man that definitely
applies to real world media too and of
course as we all know to YouTube as well
in another translation Morgan's headline
is even more hype he says Luffy has
taken vegapunk hostage and waged war
against the Marines this Luffy Waging
War against the world government is
definitely more hype than just a Navy
Skirmish at Egghead so we'll see what
the official viz translation says soon
how they choose to frame it either way
Luffy's reputation as a pirate is going
to explode again and I can't wait so
much to look forward to in the upcoming
chapters and for me seeing our crew
fight Admiral kizaru is definitely one
thing that I'm itching to see and it's
definitely going to be a highlight for
me and if you want to fully understand
my hype and see what the Admirals are
fully capable of and their powers broken
down in detail you don't want to miss my
all six Admirals and their powers
explained video link in the description
and on screen right now